[Music]
hello friends spring is here which means
it's time to smell flowers
catch butterflies and throw away old
crap and my closet is full of a bunch of
old outdated junk that really belongs in
a trash can
so that means it's time for a little
spring cleaning
[Music]
okay so let's get into it because i have
a ton of outdated things to get rid of
oh
oh you guys are gonna lose your minds
look at this fedora remember when these
were big
what did i think i was a detective
oh and look at this remember these
no one needs this much coffee
no no no no oh
look at this my old crop top can you
believe i ever used to wear this thing
man i'm telling you when i was younger
you couldn't get no clothes on me
but it would be crazy if i wore this now
it's important to get rid of things that
are no longer appropriate
like thinking britney spears is a bad
mom or a funny punchline
can you believe this i picked this up in
the mid-2000s and
much like trucker hats and ed hardy
shirts it made me look like a huge
douchebag
but it's never too late to admit a
mistake so
in the trash it goes what else is in
here
oh old sandals oh
look dumb little chokers gross
i can't believe i wore that oh and
adding o to the end of a word and
pretending it's spanish
and then acting like that's very funny
you know where that belongs
elaborate what else do we have in here
oh oakleys oh wait
a velour sweatsuit oh
i thought i was so cute and oh my gosh
look at these ah
it's the word lame on a little bracelet
can you believe that it's ableist and it
seems like it's something i should have
figured out a while ago
i'm over that then oh
look at this term spirit animal i used
it in a tweet the other day and my
friend had to come gather me
turns out this word is a nope unless
it's in a buzzfeed article
in which case it's a hard nope and let's
see
what other things we have in here oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah saying you got
gypped yeah we don't say gypsy anymore
sorry fleetwood mac the rest of that
album is great though
and what else oh of course
saying pow-wow when you really mean
meeting
hey just say meeting
i used to be such an idiot oh and this
one
used to be my favorite the idea that
every story has two sides
look sometimes the devil's advocate
ain't none but an
advocate for the devil and finally
calling tank tops wife beaters
man so stupid good news
the phrase white tank top is still very
much available
well that feels a lot better look i've
done and said all these things in the
past and at the time i didn't question
it but
now i look back and i want to barf and
that's okay
that's how learning and growth work that
uncomfortable feeling is part of it
the important thing is recognizing that
when you learn an idea or word is
hurtful to other people
it's okay to throw it right in the trash
feels pretty good too
like throwing out the idea that women
over a certain age have to dress
more conservatively hmm
you know what
i'm gonna throw out that idea yay
this has been spring cleaning
[Music]
you